it's funny because I was talking about
this with a woman named Amy errant who
was one of the cofounders of etrade and
Olivia cruises the other day we were on
a panel together at a gay mba conference
and we're talking a little bit about
what what does it mean to be again entre
program what are the challenges and both
of us sort of asserted that there really
weren't any as far as we could tell and
principally i believe that there's still
a ton of homophobia in the world and
there's a ton of homophobia in the
business world but because I've been
very out and very explicitly out in my
life and in my professional life from
the beginning I just don't hear it so if
you don't like me because I'm gay or you
don't want to do business with me
because I'm gay then I probably just
don't even know that because you're just
steering clear of me you know it's when
your closeted and people don't know that
you're gay that you hear and see the
things that are otherwise unsavory you
know and I just I don't necessarily want
to change everybody's mind in the world
about you know about homosexuality or
Judaism as I'm a Jew and or you know any
of the things that I'm you know
passionate about but what I do want is I
do want to be in an environment which
I'm respected and I have an equal
opportunity to be successful and so I'm
creating that every single day by
putting my parameters out there and
saying this is who I am gay Jewish
chubby you know now in my mid-30s this
is who I am and you know you can
self-select out of my world if you'd
like and you know so be it I think one
of the I think one of the challenges for
like all gay professional people is this
idea that you're going to be faced with
a world that's hostile to you and your
lifestyle and you know but really it
ends up being more quotidian than that I
mean when you've worked especially in
the corporate world which I mostly
issued in my in my professional career
but when you work in the professional
world most of the hassle factor of being
gay is that you on Monday morning you
come into the office and your friends
are talking about their kids and their
you know their spouse and what they did
for the weekend and the golfing that
they did and if your lifestyle is not
those things if you're not a gay person
with kids and a spouse and golfing and
you're sort of forced to like interpret
what part of your life the other person
does
doesn't want to hear and what's
contextually relevant and you know what
is always I'm going to make them
uncomfortable and I think I think that's
actually a complicated dance at first
and then over time what you realizes you
a gain traction on that so not being
Pollyanna I am saying that I think
single straight people have some of the
same issues in a culture where you're
around a lot of married people are
married people with children there's a
sort of expectation often that people
who are married with children can go
home at four o'clock because they have
to attend to their kids and of course
who would say no you can't go pick your
kids up from school you know we're asked
a single person or the person without
kids doesn't get to do those things and
that I think is more out like a family
status equality fairness issue than it
is a sexuality fairness and equality
issue and so a lot of so to me my
observation has been that most issues
related to sexuality in the workplace
are actually issues of family status and
gender and rather than sexuality
strictly speaking and that once you put
those things into context then there's a
layer certainly of like explicitly
sexuality related issues but most of it
is about family status and gender I will
say one thing though which is I have the
benefit of being an entrepreneur and the
benefit of living in you know in the
technology business and the games
industry and and being an entrepreneur
in those environments and so in those in
the context of entrepreneurship and
technology and the games industry of
course I can be out I mean it's my
company so in that way I can build a
corporate culture that matches the
environment that I want to work in and
our built with people who I respect and
who respect me and who I feel
comfortable with and with whom I want to
come into work every single day and
enjoy the basically the relationship
that I'm building with them you know and
that's a degree of control that I don't
have in many other aspects of being an
entrepreneur but I certainly do in terms
of who gets hired to work at my company
and that's definitely one thing that's
rewarding about being an entrepreneur
that you don't necessarily get when you
work in the corporate world so I
appreciate it if you're a you know if
you're just starting out in your career
and you want to go work at you know some
big finance company air that
department of defense or something crazy
like that then your considerations are
probably different from mine but I I try
to live a I work so much I try to
integrate my life as much as possible so
that can enjoy all aspects of it